hbo is making a game of thrones prequel
tv show
called house of the dragon based on the
targaryen history book
fire and blood but they're also
developing another prequel show based on
the tales of dunk and
egg a series of novellas set 90 years
before
a game of thrones dunk is a young hedge
knight
he's not particularly smart or skilled
but
he's tall and strong and he's determined
to be an honorable knight
egg is his loyal squire he has a bald
head
and a big mouth and he's secretly a
targaryen prince
and future king of westeros we've
already made videos about their first
two stories
where dunk fights in a trial at a
tournament then in a conflict between
minor lords
but the third story is called the
mystery night
and it's a tale of conspiracy sorcery
prophecy
a dragon egg painted dwarfs homoerotic
jousting jokes
and a little baby walder frey
the mystery knight was adapted to a
graphic novel with art by mike s
miller at the start of the story dunk
and egg are traveling north towards
winterfell
planning to help the starks fight
against the ironborn
this is a time of political tension in
westeros
because the king aerys targaryen is seen
as
weak and he lets his uncle bloodraven
rule the kingdom
for him many people hate bloodraven they
call him
a sorcerer a bastard and a kinslayer
because 16 years ago bloodraven's
half-brother daemon blackfyre
started a rebellion to take the throne
but at the battle of the redgrass field
bloodraven killed his half-brother in a
hail of arrows
and daemon's surviving sons fled east
across the sea
now 16 years later some people want the
blackfyres to return
dunk and eggs see a preacher who says
that bloodraven is evil
and the blackfyres should rule westeros
bloodraven doesn't tolerate
treason so he has the preacher killed
bloodraven has spies
all over westeros it's said he has a
thousand
eyes and one one eye on his face because
he lost an eye in the blackfyre
rebellion
and the thousand eyes of his spies
dunk and egg take care while traveling
because these
are perilous times also
egg gets a new hat and he gives his old
hat to their mule and he even cuts out
little holes for his ears which is
[ __ ] adorable and the mule is named
maester because it was given to them by
egg's brother
a young maester aemon on the road
dunk and egg meet a group of lords
there's gorman peak
alan cockshaw and this guy who calls
himself
john the fiddler pique and cockshaw are
both rude to dunk
but the fiddler is friendly he says that
he's a humble travelling hedge knight
like dunk
or like how do you do fellow hedge
knights but he
wears rich clothes and talks like a lord
so he's obviously not who he says he is
the fiddler and his friends are up to
something
the fiddler hits on dunk admiring how
large
dunk is saying he would love to cross
swords with dunk
and wants to try his lance on him but
dunk is oblivious to the flirting
the fiddler is going to a castle called
white walls for a wedding and a
tournament held by lord butterwell
so dunk and egg head there too they hope
to win some money at the jousting
and eat some good food at the feast
along the way
they meet some knights there's kyle the
cat
who has ginger whiskers like a cat a
mysterious man called maynard plum
and a proud young knight called glendon
ball
glendon says he's the son of quentin
ball
a famous knight nicknamed fireball
fireball was the master at arms who
taught young targaryens how to fight
he trained king aerys and egg's father
micah
and taught bloodraven and daemon
blackfyre
when daemon started his rebellion
fireball joined the blackfyres but
died before the battle of the red grass
field
glendon hopes to prove himself as a
great knight
like fireball by winning the tournament
at white walls
and getting the grand prize a dragon egg
the last dragon died 60 years ago and
the remaining dragon eggs haven't
hatched since
so a famously shitty king called aegon
the unworthy
once gave a dragon egg to a lord
butterwell in return
for sex with his daughters now lord
butterwell is offering this egg as a
tournament prize
and dunk wonders why he'd give away
something
so valuable at white walls lord
butterwell
marries a daughter of lord frey we also
see lord frey's four-year-old son who 90
years later
grows up to be lord walder frey in the
main series
dunk says this kid is snot-nosed and
hideous and has such an irritating laugh
that he wants to throw the boy down a
well
if he did then maybe the red wedding
wouldn't have happened
90 years later the lords proposed toasts
to the bride and groom
to the king and to the king's hand
bloodraven
but many at the feast hate bloodraven
and refuse to toast him
and when they toast to the king glendon
holds his wine cup
over a basin of water this is a
reference to a real historical practice
in the 1700s britain was ruled by house
hanover
but a group called the jacobites wanted
the stuarts to be king
charles stewart lived in exile overseas
in france
so when the jacobites toasted to the
king they held their cups over water
to show that their king is charles
stewart the king
over the water in the mystery night
glendon does the same thing
showing that he supports the blackfyres
over the water
in essos real history like this inspired
a lot of the song of ice and fire series
so dunk and eggs start to realize that
many people at this tournament
support the blackfyres not the
targaryens
egg says this is a traitors tourney
still dunk enjoys the feast and drinks a
lot and when he goes out for a pierce he
overhears a conversation between gorman
pique
and butterworld's son-in-law black tom
heddle
tom complains that they don't have
bittersteel's
support bittersteel is the half-brother
of daemon blackfyre and was one of his
main supporters in the blackfyre
rebellion
when daemon was killed bittersteel went
east with daemon's sons
and has plotted invasion of westeros
ever since
pique says that they don't need
bittersteel's help because their prince
had a dream
that the dragon egg will hatch so
peak and black tom and lord butterwell
and lord frey
are plotting a second blackfyre
rebellion
this whole tournament and wedding is an
excuse to bring together blackfyre
supporters to kick off a war for the
throne
but who is their prince with these
dreams
at the feast some dwarfs perform and
dunk carries the bride to her bedding
dunk is really drunk by then so he goes
for some air
and finds john the fiddler the fiddler
is also pretty wasted and he says that
his dreams come true like he once
dreamed that his brothers would die
and then they died he also had a dream
that dunk will join the kingsguard the
greatest knights in the realm
and he dreamed that a dragon egg will
hatch
at white walls the fiddler believes that
he will win the dragon egg at this
tournament will hatch a dragon
and become the king of westeros with
dunk
in his kingsguard so the fiddler is the
prince in pig's conspiracy
cause his real name is daemon blackfire
ii
son of damon the first he came across
the sea
to start a new war for the throne
and there were hints of this earlier the
fiddler gives a toast to his brave
brothers which refers to his dead
blackfyre brothers
the fiddler smells of eastern spice
because he just came across from essos
in the east
the fiddler dyes his hair black to hide
the blonde
but his eyes are the purple of
targaryens
and blackfyres pique shuts up the
fiddler before he gives away their whole
conspiracy
and dunk falls into bed
in the morning it's hot dunk is super
hungover he barely remembers that
blackfyre stuff
and he just wants to get through the
jousting tournament without throwing up
dunk isn't actually very good at
jousting with a lance he's much better
with a sword in a fight
but he just needs to win two jousts to
make some money
his first opponent is some guy called
uthor the snail
so like how tough can he be right dunk
and the snail
charge at each other and dunk gets
smashed in the head really hard and
falls down
dunk wakes up hours later with the
mother of all headaches but
alive he says hi to the dwarfs from the
feast last night and one of them
stinks like a toilet which is weird but
dunk has bigger problems because at this
tournament
when you're defeated in a joust the
knight who beat you
gets your horse and sword and armor and
you've got to pay a ransom to get your
stuff back
but dunk lost his first joust and he
doesn't have the money for a ransom so
it looks like his life as a knight is
over
maynard plum says that dunk should just
keep his stuff
and run but dunk refuses to cheat
and he goes to give his stuff to uthor
the snail
uthor's tent looks plain from the
outside but inside it's luxurious and
comfortable
uthor lurks inside there like a snail in
his shell
it turns out that uthor is like a
professional
jousting grifter cause he's really good
at jousting but he hides his skill
he deliberately never wins tournaments
only getting second or
third prize so that people always
underestimate him
and he bribes the people running this
tournament so that he goes up against
knights who look tough but actually suck
so that the snail and his squire can
make money
by taking bets against himself
uthor offers to give dunk his arms back
if he joins in
on uthor's con but dunk refuses this
dishonesty and corruption
he would rather give up his knighthood
than give up his honor
uthor tells dunk the story of glendon
ball
the kid who says he's the son of
fireball
apparently glendon's mother was a camp
follower called
penny jenny who had sex with so many
soldiers that there's no way of knowing
if fireball
really is glendon's father glendon was
raised in a brothel and he was only
knighted
in return for a night having sex with
his sister
so all the lords of this tournament look
down on glendon
as the baseborne son of a [ __ ] knighted
dishonorably glendon hoped to win some
respect
in the jousting cause glendon is a
really talented knight
but no matter how many times he proves
his skill
the lords still treat him like trash
dunk sympathizes he's often been treated
the same way
as a bastard orphan from flea bottom
it's so unfair that in this class system
people are judged by who their parents
were instead of by their actions
and their talent as a japanese
philosopher once said
the circumstances of one's birth are
irrelevant it is what you do
with the gift of life that determines
who you are
it's ironic that glendon and dunk are
treated like they're not real knights
when these guys are practically the only
honest honorable knights here
uthor has his jousting grift maynard
says to break the rules kyle the cat
deliberately
loses his joust to suck up to a lord and
it turns out that lord peake is bribing
people to make sure that daemon wins the
tournament
but when he tries to bribe glendon to
lose to daemon glendon
refuses so glendon might not really be
fireball's son and dunk might not really
have been knighted
in his first story but still these guys
are the truest knights here and they
become
friends as the jousting continues rain
falls down from dark ominous clouds
butterwell's dragon egg mysteriously
goes missing
so peak falsely accuses glendon of
stealing it
and then a different egg goes missing
dunk's squire egg
disappears alan cockshaw says he knows
where to find egg so
dunk follows him into a trap
it turns out that alan is in love with
daemon
and they'd had a relationship for years
it's
actually hinted that daemon being gay
was why bittersteel didn't support his
rebellion
but alan is jealous that daemon now
wants dunk instead of him
so alan actually paid uthor to kill dunk
in the joust and that's why uthor hit
dunk in the head
since that didn't work allen tries to
kill dunk himself
he attacks dunk with a dagger so dunk
beats him with a rock
and throws him down a well the excellent
radio westeros podcast
points out that this fight between dunk
and allen
is similar to a fight in the main books
between brienne and a guy called
shagwell which also involves a dagger
and a rock
and a well in dunk's fight rock baits
dagger but
in brienne's fight dagger beats rock
it's like
rock paper scissors and in the previous
dunk and egg story
dunk fought a man in a stream which is
similar to brienne's fight with jaime
which in the books
happens in a stream and in the first
dunkin egg story
dunk defeats arion in a similar way to
how brienne defeats loris tyrell
by knocking him down raising his visor
and forcing him to yield
so in each of these three fights
brienne's story
echoes dunk's story which makes sense
because author george martin has said
that
dunk and brienne are related dunk and
brienne
are both tall powerful warriors who
travel westeros with their loyal squires
by their sides
struggling to be true knights in a
society that
looks down on them so dunk kills alan
and then suddenly
maynard plum appears and helps dunk with
his wound
maynard seems to know all about daemon
and pique's conspiracy but
he only gives vague hints at his own
motives and identity
he tells dunk to find egg in the sept
egg had wanted to help dunk and to
prevent this blackfyre rebellion against
his family the targaryens
so egg went to butterwell and revealed
his true identity
as prince aegon targaryen and threatened
butterwell with attack and execution
egg acts with the confidence and courage
of a prince
black tom heddle tries to take egg
hostage so he and dunk have a big
fight and dunk proves that he really is
better with a sword
than with a lance shit's really hitting
the fan
so dunk tells egg to ride for safety but
dunk
walks right up to daemon in front of
everyone reveals his conspiracy
and demands justice for glendon ball
dunk knows that it's super dangerous for
him to publicly oppose lord peake
he's standing alone against a deadly
political conspiracy to protect this
bloke glendon who he
barely knows uthor asks if dunk is
gallant
or just stupid but to dunk
foolishness and heroism are sometimes
the same thing
in his first story tanzel said all men
are fools
and all men are knights fighting against
impossible odds to help others is
foolish but
it's also truly human and
heroic luckily daemon wants the truth
he didn't know that pique was rigging
the whole tournament for him
so daemon challenges glendon to a trial
by combat to decide his innocence
glendon was savagely tortured in the
dungeon
he's been beaten and burned he's missing
teeth and fingernails
and now to win his life he's got to
defeat daemon
glendon laughs at the irony cause
glendon
wanted to fight for the blackfyres just
as his father fireball had
glendon would have joined daemon if he'd
asked but since glendon had refused to
lose and cheat for this conspiracy now
he's got a fight against daemon daemon
washes out his hair dye and reveals his
blackfyre colours
looking just like his father daemon the
first
glendon has a fireball on his shield
just like
his supposed father quentin ball the
story asks
is the boy his father's son is glendon a
great knight like fireball
is daemon a true warrior and leader like
his father daemon the first
the two knights crash together and
daemon
splats into the mud the crowd laughs
and calls him the brown dragon
so damon ii is not a great warrior
and leader like his father daemon the
first but
glendon is a great knight like fireball
even though fireball probably isn't
glendon's father
it's like how jon snow isn't ned stark's
son
but he does embody ned's values and
legacy
so maybe greatness and family isn't
something
in your blood maybe it's something you
can choose
suddenly a targaryen army arrives to
crush this rebellion
led by the hand of the king bloodraven
daemon tries to rally the castle to
fight against bloodraven to rise in a
second blackfyre rebellion
but daemon's cause seems hopeless
and false he didn't win this tournament
it was rigged and he got beaten into the
mud by a bastard boy anyway
he doesn't have a dragon egg or the
dragon that he said
would hatch from it he doesn't have
bittersteel or an
army and he doesn't have the legendary
sword blackfyre
the sword that gave daemon the first his
name
politics in westeros is about symbols of
power
and legitimacy and daemon has nothing
so in the end daemon rides out against
bloodraven
alone bloodraven arrests daemon and
burns his blackfyre flag the first
blackfyre
rebellion had perished on the red grass
field in blood and glory
the second blackfyre rebellion ended
with a whimper
so bloodraven arrests everyone and
decides who to pardon
and who to kill he spares butterwell but
takes his money
and destroys his castle and he kills
lord pique
daemon he keeps as a prisoner cause as
long as he's alive his younger brothers
in
essos can't claim to be the new
blackfyre king
lord frey who married his daughter to
lord bodawell
and seemed to be involved in the
conspiracy doesn't get punished
and seems friendly with bloodraven so it
looks like he might have switched sides
to inform on the conspiracy to
bloodraven
so even 90 years ago you can't trust a
bloody fray
then dunk faces bloodraven's judgment
and bloodraven got his name from the
raven-shaped birthmark on his face
he's an albino with red eyes and his
skin and hair
are white as bone bloodraven looks
similar to elric of melnibane
a fantasy character by michael morcock
who is also a warrior
and a sorcerer with red eyes and skin
and hair that's bone white so author
george martin is obviously drawing
inspiration here
bloodraven asks what the hell dunk and
prince egg were doing in the middle of
this rebellion
dunk says that they just sort of
accidentally wandered into it but eggs
says
they had it all under control egg
demands some gold so that dunk can buy
back his arms and armor
and he demands that glendon should be
released and rewarded
egg finds a lot of confidence in this
story
he confronts butterwell reveals his
identity and acts like a prince
and bloodraven says that this fulfills
daemon's dream
about a dragon hatching it wasn't a
literal dragon hatching from a literal
egg
the egg was egg and the dragon
is his new confidence as prince aegon
targaryen
but what happened to the actual dragon
egg who stole
it bloodraven reveals that those dwarfs
who performed at the feast
worked for him and one of them climbed
up through a toilet to steal the dragon
egg for bloodraven
that foul-smelling dwarf who dunks or
was the thief
so dunk and egg ride off into the sunset
but
there's another mystery that the story
doesn't answer
the mysterious maynard plum what was he
up to
he's this knowing watching figure
throughout the story but at the end he
disappears right before bloodraven
arrives dunk notices that there's
something strange
about maynard's face for one moment he
appears
as a hooded shape with a single pale
eye it's implied that maynard plum
is actually bloodraven in disguise
because bloodraven is said to be a
sorcerer that he can
change his face and that crows and
wolves
spy for him which is probably completely
true because 90 years later bloodraven
becomes the three-eyed crow
a magical greenseer who trains bran to
control animals to spy
and when duncan egg meet maynard he's in
a grove of weirwood stumps and weirwoods
are connected to the magic of the old
gods
butterwell's castle has rafters made of
weirwood which might also hint that
bloodraven is watching
but bloodraven's disguise as maynard is
probably a kind of magic
called a glamour because in the main
books melisandre
magically disguises mance raider to look
like rattleshirt
and this magic is connected to a ruby
man swears
similarly maynard wears this giant
moonstone brooch
which is probably the key to his magical
disguise
so all this time bloodraven the hand of
the king
was watching the treason and conspiracy
at white walls
learning who the traitors are securing
the dragon egg
deciding who to execute later but
at the same time he's also having a
bunch of fun
he drinks and gossips and jokes he jokes
that
maybe he's the son of aegon targaryen iv
when bloodraven really is the bastard
son of aegon iv
he says that the north is too cold for
him which is funny because bloodraven
later goes
far far north beyond the wall at the
feast
maynard makes crude jokes about tits and
[ __ ]
and he calls lord butterwell lord
butterbutt
bloodraven is a ruthless politician
spying on his enemies but he's
also a magical trickster dressing up and
getting on the beers with the boys it's
a lot like the norse god odin
who also had one eye and spied with
ravens
and also liked to magically disguise
himself as a mortal man
and make jokes about duties so you can
see inspiration from
mythology fantasy and real-life history
in this story the story also reveals
the dangers of dreams and prophecies
daemon is totally convinced that his
rebellion will succeed because of his
dragon dreams
and his dreams do come true but not in
the way he expected
because the hatching dragon egg is
actually a metaphor
for prince egg and yeah dunk does
eventually join the kingsguard but he
guards king egg
not king daemon daemon's dreams don't
lie
he just misinterprets them and believes
what he wants to believe
this happens all throughout the series
melisandre convinces herself that
stannis is the prophesied hero azor ahai
and she mistakes a vision of alice
karstark for a vision of arya the vision
was true
but her reading was false cersei
convinces herself
that the prophecy of maggie the frog
means that margery and tyrion will
destroy her
but it might actually be daenerys and
jaime and cersei's own
self-destructiveness that destroy her
and the targaryens have been tormented
by
dreams and prophecies for centuries king
aerys king joharis
maester aemon and rhaegar were all
obsessed with prophecy
hoping to bring back the dragons or the
prince that was promised to save the
world
but aemon says that all of his brothers
were killed by their dragon dreams
daeron drank himself
to oblivion arion drank wildfire
thinking it would transform him into a
dragon
and egg had dragon dreams that led to
death at summerhall though that's a
story for another video
and above it all for a hundred years
bloodraven has watched over house
targaryen
ruthlessly protecting the royal
bloodline from the blackfyres
what dreams and prophecies has he seen
and what do they mean for the destiny of
daenerys and jon snow
the last of the targaryen bloodline who
themselves have prophetic dreams of
fighting the darkness with
fire if dunk and egg is anything to go
by
their dreams don't mean what we think
the mystery night is the third and final
of the published dunk and egg stories
but author george martin plans to write
more maybe 10
or 12 to tell the whole life stories of
dunk and
egg he says possible future titles
include the she-wolves of winterfell
about the starks in the north which some
fans think might involve a romance
between dunk
and a young old nan the village hero
is set in the riverlands and might
involve the infamous brute of bracken
the champion might be about dunk's fight
against the laughing storm lionel
baratheon
the kingsguard and the lord commander
might be about dunk in
king egg's kingsguard there are still
three more blackfyre rebellions to cover
and the story of how egg becomes king
dunk might reunite with his crush tanzel
or with rohan or
get revenge on venice there are lots of
possibilities for future dunkin egg
stories
and maybe their final tale will end with
summerhall
for now there are three published
stories and you can get all of them on
audiobook for free
right now at audible.com asx
a knight of the seven kingdoms includes
all three dunk and egg stories
read on audiobook by harry lloyd the
actor who played viserys on game of
thrones
or you could get dune or his dark
materials or the expats
just sign up for a premium plus trial
membership
and you get an audio book to keep even
if you cancel the trial later
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audio books and
shows in the audible plus catalog
the trial is free so it's a pretty good
deal sign up at audible.com
asx or text asx to 500 500
thanks for watching and thanks to the
patrons including matthew mchale monty
owen jones luca marago savarelli mike
batco
and willie hardy cheers
you